[Music]  beyond the run to tour is finally here  [Music]  after weeks of the bee hive buzzing  Beyonce officially announced she's going  on another joint tour with husband jay-z  [Music]  queen bee posted a black and white  Instagram video of the couple with  moments from their first on the run tour  including promo pics of J and B for  their upcoming tour run it's set to kick  off on June 6 in the UK before coming  stateside on July 25th well fans are  anticipating a great show as both J and  B released their new albums four four  four and lemonade which address their  marriage woes nobody wins when the  family feels on the run to tour will  stop in 21 cities across the u.s. and  tickets go on sale March 19 to the  general public  [Music]  you